people are like if you watch like game
of thrones for the first like half the
season you have no idea what the [ __ ] is
going on yeah yeah but if you stick with
it eventually you get it maybe you go
back and watch those first six episodes
again
did you watch game of thrones i did okay
good did you like it
loved it and just like everybody else
the ending made me like i was like this
sucks so hard that it ruined the entire
series for me
yeah but you know just let me just add
this though it's the pressure i mean
when you have a cultural
show like that that's a phenomenon right
and the globe is watching it right i
can't imagine being in
the writers room whatever and just
trying to figure out because you have so
many different voices as well
i'm sure hbo maybe maybe they don't give
notes probably because the show's so big
and that they respect the show runners
but
you would have to think that there's
just like
months of people just together on a
board
trying to figure this out and people
arguing about certain things right
because it's not like
there's one guy like you know aaron
sorkin that's going you know
my word this is it this is the final
this is it right
i'm sure there's voices in there so i
think it's it was inevitable that it was
going to be bad
i mean it was inevitable that would be a
kind of a let down considering
everything that had been going on i mean
endings
are extremely tough to to pull off but
this was
i mean it was almost a slap in the face
they just kind of like let's just get
this
over with all right that that i think
upset people
yeah here's another thing the problem is
is um there
it's like i'm not i'm not comparing it
to the show lost but
the show lost had they would ever every
season they would bring up these new
things
right like the polar bear or some wind
or whatever it might be the [ __ ]
and um there was just you just knew as a
viewer
oh they're not going to be able to
explain half of this [ __ ]
well when you when the whole thing is
like there's going to be a twist we're
going to explain it in the end
and when people figure it out when
everyone's like it's purgatory they're
in purgatory right and they're like no
no and at the end like they're all
sitting in a church together you're like
this is [ __ ] purgatory like you guys
lied to us yeah
when you if you mess up a twist like
that it's really uh
it really ruins everything yeah it does
but the voyage but how about this what
about
is an analogy where you mean like they
say you know um
it's about the journey not the end i
like to say when it comes to game of
thrones i'll remember the red wedding
i'll remember you know the mountain
versus the viper i'll remember those
things that i loved about it
but i would not go back and watch battle
of the bastards
oh what i just rewatched hard home do
you remember heart home
no heart home was when jon snow was up
there with the wildlings right
and he's in some fishing village or
whatever and they have all the dragon
glass and stuff right
the giants there right and they're
trying to get all the wildlings onto
these little boats yes right that was
great and all of a sudden on the cliffs
right
they show the guys and then they're
falling what a [ __ ] episode i
remember i was at some
i was at like a party like a friend's
house was like 10 people and everyone's
getting ready to leave and they're like
actually we heard tonight's episode of
game of thrones supposed to be awesome
do you want to watch it
and we got stoned and for the next like
hour and a half we were just like
completely zoned in blown away that was
maybe one of the best
yeah experiences of the of the show yeah
even
with with with you and your family we
would
on sundays get together and when we went
on a family vacation
we all crammed into one room yeah and we
were screaming remember that oh yeah
yeah
and i remember going out on the balcony
of the hotel and just like
you know i mean ponder pondering about
it and analyze with my cigarette you
know how i do
i look out in the sky and i just i'll
just sometimes i'll go
wow you know to myself you know what i
mean what a great show man
and there's not a there's there i think
there's not another show like that right
now
where it's a cultural where everybody
watches it
yeah that was i mean that was the big
part of the community that you had to
watch it
even though everything's on demand and
streaming now you had to watch it right
away
because there were articles published
immediately you wanted to read and see
things you had to talk about it
but yeah that's that's missing also
twitter too twitter was crazy you
couldn't turn on twitter
you know i mean there's just no way but
what i just i wow what a [ __ ]
i miss it and also you and you i you
also understood why
what's the jon snow's real name uh he's
a targaryen
no no he the actor oh oh um
did you get the actors on the [ __ ]
turtles kid
yeah when he you know when we got really
depressed when the show was over
yeah you could understand why as an
actor i would never want to would you
ever want to be on a show like that
a show like that yes but i understand
like i understand how tough it would be
like i've talked to people who
have acted like i had friends who were
in that movie um
the king kong one the the new one yeah
yeah skull island yeah
and then like we were just [ __ ] stuck
in vietnam for like a year and a half
and the movies the movie's two hours
long so like why do we have to be there
that long that that would drive me crazy
yeah wearing a backpack and and and
pretending to be a military guy
would drive me nuts well i have two
lines and i leave for hungary next week
for six weeks i have two lines
and i go how many days are sitting maybe
one or two i go
i gotta be there for six weeks yeah you
know before two and then um and then
the whole time i know me i'm gonna be
thinking about those two lines
yeah i'll just be laying in bed just
saying the lines over and over again
and then when i when it's actually go
time it's going to be completely
gone i was i don't